hello everybody welcome to this
lecture grandmaster choice this is
spanish grandmaster pepe going on it's
a great pleasure as usual to be here
with all of you guys
and uh what are we gonna do today well
i'm gonna provide you with an extremely
dangerous repertoire against the french
defense
and in particular against the fort knox
variation
so just hello to everybody there in
the chat in the youtube chat i'll be
paying attention uh
to the youtube chat all the time so i
hope this
will be an interactive lecture so you
guys can
provide a lot of suggestions i'll be
asking you some questions as well
um hopefully we'll have some fun so
i'm gonna check if so yes
everything's fine regarding audio and
video um
my face is my face i can exist i cannot
fix that but
at least you can hear me properly and
you can see something right
so okay uh what is the forknox variation
it's one of the most solid
approaches uh for the black pieces
when you are when you are where somebody
is playing the french
okay so let's start so e4 e6 this is the
french defense and uh just one second
guys
so just one second and
we are ready to go okay
so e for e6 d4 d5 this is the french
defense here
and there are different options here you
can play the advanced
variation with e5 the exchange variation
with etx d5
even bishop d3 is a very interesting
move
but the two main moves are by far knight
c3
or knight d2 knight d2 is called the tar
rush
variation after knight c3 black can try
to play
knight f6 going for the classical french
also
bishop b4 devvin our variation extremely
difficult to understand as well
okay but the point is after knight c3 or
knight d2
black can take on e4 knight takes e4 and
bishop d7 this is
the so-called fort knox variation
what is black intending to do here in
this position well in many cases
black is going to bring this bishop to
c6 it's gonna put a lot of pressure on
e4
and at some point there's gonna be a
knight on f3 and in many positions black
will take this knight on f3 and we'll
reach some sort of
scandinavian setup right we'll wear
black puts uh
the pawn on c6 and it's extremely solid
in that position
so what are we gonna do here i'm gonna
provide you with an extremely dangerous
weapon
uh against uh this black setup and we're
gonna
be ready to sacrifice a whole piece in
many many cases
so i see a lot of people uh good
afternoon to yetia jeremias
mitran pradet kumar sorry for my
pronunciation
i guess that's an indian name right and
uh
so here we're gonna play knight f3
so let's see take stakes bishop d7
knight of three and bishop
c6 and the main line by far is bishop d3
or
knight g3 but here i'm gonna propose you
this move knight e
to g5 an extremely dangerous move for
black
because now this knight is targeting f7
e6
and here black has several options in
most of
them we're gonna sacrifice a piece in
the next move
and it's completely playable and i
played this line myself in a classical
game
with a big success success sorry
so what will you play here with the
black pieces
i'm gonna ask you guys so what do you
think about this move bishop takes f3
which is very typical in this position
so when i get rid of this bishop on c6
and then play
c6
so what do you think about about the
bishop
f3 it's a very bad move it's a very poor
move because after queen takes f3
there is a double attack on f7 and on b7
and basically
black has to resign there's no proper
way to protect both of them
right so that's why bishop f3 is not a
very good move
so now i'm gonna ask you what happens
after the move
h6 what do you think about this move
it looks cool because uh the first
glance we could think that the only
square for this knight is h3
right and therefore the knight on h3 is
basically doing nothing right
so what do we play here with the white
pieces against this
h6 it's actually a very bad move but
you're gonna find
you have to find the reason why that's
right hussein
knight f7 this is just completely
winning for white
so this is why there are many tricks
in this position so key in f7 now 95
that's right now no matter where you go
for example you go to e7 there is knight
g6
just winning the rook and if you go to
e8
we all know the answer right queen h5
boom and this actually checkmate is this
checkmate i think
checkmating one two three four moves
can you spot the checkmate so give me
the whole variation
yeah forcing moves captures checks and
threats
by the way i'm in sweden because i'm
gonna play here the swedish league and
it's extremely cold here for spanish you
know
it's freezing for me i was in my uh hot
granada
in the south of spain still enjoying
some good weather and here in sweden
it's just so
freezing for me so how do we checkmate
black spawning here come on check mate
in four moves
it's not that difficult check check
check check
check check check checkmate so
that's right queen f7 king d6 and now
knight c4 check only square
yeah that's right paul paul is
paying attention so king d5 queen of
three
king d4 and then bishop e3 this is just
checkmate
so then the kin made a fantastic journey
from e8
to d4 and now it's gonna be checkmated
so that's why
h6 is just a terrible move
and so many people like 20 games at
least
in my database they went in this in this
position for the move
knight to f6 what do you think about
this move looks like a natural
development move just intend to bring
some pieces but it's actually a losing
move as well
hi luis good to see you around here
so 906 also terrible for black
because yeah that's right hussein
hussein
is very strong today knight e5 and i
guarantee you that if you play this line
a lot in blitz games or even rapid games
some people are gonna fall for this
trick
i mean in my database even in classical
games 2100 players they just played
knight f6 and they reside after
knighting fight because there's no way
of stopping knight f7
just winning a very important pawn
attacking the rook on h8 with a fork on
d8
so basically black has to resign in this
position
okay so not f6 not a good move h6 just
losing bishop s3
just losing so in this position there
are
other options for example bishop d6
sorry bishop d6 bishop e7
and knight d7 these three
are the main moves so let's start by
bishop g6
so what do you think we're gonna play in
this position
would you sacrifice on f7 would you just
play
con with bishop d3
or what candidates
what candidate moves you have in your
mind in this position
what's up jorge best regards from sweden
and will you take an f7
or would you just uh develop a piece and
then try to go for shark castle or even
bishop d3 queen e2 and then
aim to go for long castle in this
position knight f7 okay
knight f7 it's the move that we're going
to recommend
and is very very playable and again it's
extremely hard for black to
defend in this position so knight f7
king takes f7 only move and now king g5
and basically black has two main options
here keaney eight
and kini seven probably you would think
that kini seven
is the best move in this position
because it protects the e6 pawn
and hopefully your opponents will think
the same because skinny seven is in fact
uh a little bit worse than kidney eight
so let's start with keen e7 and now we
have to develop pieces attacking
our opponent's weaknesses so how do we
develop pieces and at the same time
we attacked our uh main upon sweetness
which is of course
e6 if we manage to enter in that square
it will be
very very painful for black in this
position right and imagine a knight on
e6
just controlling everything targeting g7
so that's that's why
we developed the bishop to c4 very very
good mithra
bishop c4 we're now attacking the pawn
on e6
and here black has two options the first
one is bishop d5
the second is bishop d7 so let's start
by
checking bishop d7 which is
not the best move in this position
because we just go sure castle
and after h6 what
are we supposed to play here in this
position now that we have castled
we're going to bring some pieces to the
e file right
and this is very important whenever j is
again on the
on the e file which is not castled we're
gonna uh
put some pressure in this e5 right yeah
jorge jimenez
that's right knight e6 using this pin on
the ee file so after bishop v6
we can just play rookie one right and
then after
knight f6 we just play bishop e6 and
even though this skin escapes
by a c8 after some move like c4 we have
full compensation for the sacrifice
piece because we have
two pawns for the piece we got the
bishop pair which is extremely important
in chess
and also our kin is safe and uh
what else well we have more space in
this position
and actually the end the engines say
that
white is much better in this position so
if you don't trust me i
can understand that you do not trust
this stupid spanish guy
you can trust the engine and the engine
says white is much better in this
position there are many ideas here you
can
try to go c5 you can try to go
d5 reinforcing this bishop on e6 i like
c5
and then bring this bishop to f4 for
example then queen d3
communicating the rooks the g6 square is
very very weak
and it's not easy for black to play yeah
because
this rook is not coming to the action
and whenever you play
g5 you're you know pushing too too high
your pawns on the key inside and
basically
i i would take white uh definitely in
this position right
so what about queenie too instead of
shark castle
so very interesting question from
crusade queen e2
that's a very decent move but i guess
now i can just play keen f8
and the thing is whenever you take on e6
let's say bishop b6 here
you can just play queen e7 and now the
king is still in the center
and you're gonna go h6 so i think this
is not the best way to go for the white
pieces but definitely queen e2 is
another
idea in this kind of positions yeah we
want to put pressure on e6
but it makes more sense that just to go
short castle and then
96 is going to come anyway and joking is
safe on g1 so there's no trade of queens
in any case
the attack is very strong as jorge is
suggesting
okay so this is a very interesting
repertoire guys
so maybe after this video lecture
you can go and take the notes for
example in the beginning
and it will not take you more than half
an hour and then you will have a nice
preparation
for your tournaments yeah that's right
jorge sure castle brings another piece
into the attack the rook
not only the queen so we have two heavy
pieces putting pressure on e6
which is nice okay so we were saying to
so bishop d6 knight f7
king f7 knight g5 keen e7
and now bishop c4 and we analyze the
move bishop g7 how about
bishop t5 and now i wanna i want you to
calculate 4c moves against captures
checks and threats and here there is a
way
where white can win an exchange very
easily just with forcing moves yeah
i'm gonna be insisting like hell
uh in all this but it's
quite quite important you know it's like
my mom whenever i
i travel abroad come on pepe pepe yo she
calls me pepe
which means small pepe yeah i i'm 33
years old you know
but spanish moms they won't change you
know
so she calls me pepe yo and she asked me
to wear a jacket you know
mom i know i know i have to wear a
jacket yeah she tells me don't forget to
wear a jacket so it's the same with
forcing moves
so what do you play here with the white
pieces
georgie kalatos i guess you're from
georgia right
bishop d5 that's right e takes e5 and
now
and now what again four sim moves queen
e2
that's that's great jorge
and uh yes if black kings goes to f6
there's checkmate on e6 right
if black goes to f8 there is a fork on
e6 so only move basically is king d7 and
now you can just play
queen e6 check this king has to go for a
tour
to c6 to visit some caves and now knight
f7 just wins
an exchange right let's say queen f6
takes takes
and knight h8 there's nobody that can't
stop this knight going back
by f7 so basically
white is winning so that's why there is
another
try for black here who black can try to
hold the position after bishop takes
d5 and i'm going to give you the option
to find best black smooth in this
position
which is not e takes d5 but an
intermediate move
so let's see if you guys find this move
yes luis ray castillo bishop b4 check
that's fine
intermediate move and here we're going
to propose bishop d2
bishop takes e2 queen takes e2 and queen
takes d5
so it looks like black managed to hold
uh because now e6 is sort of protected
and we have just uh one point uh in
return for the piece
so we're gonna do something we have to
play extremely
dynamically in this position what means
open files using the fact that this skin
is still in the center
and there's a very nice move in this
position so
what would you play here with the white
pieces as i'm telling you you go knight
e3
just play very shy so black is gonna
bring
his pieces out knight f6 knight d7
rookie eight and then
black is going for an artificial castle
and
we'll have some troubles so
okay there are different uh normal moves
in this position for white c3 c3 is the
kind of move that you don't want to play
because we said we had to react
instantaneously
and dynamically open files bring pieces
to the action
c3 is just a very calm move that just
protects
opponent e4 so i wouldn't go for this
but nice suggestion sure castle is
definitely a move
it's definitely a move that you have to
consider more candidate moves guys
sure castle yeah that's right mithran i
like the move do you suggest
c4 very very nice move
so we want to open the c file and now
black has three options the first one is
just to take on g2 which is
losing in the spot because of long
castle
and now we have so many so many
interesting options we can bring the
rook to the e
file we can play d file to open the e
file
and just uh just very good for us
so queen g2 just loses immediately
there's
another option which is queen takes c4
and i guess we all know the answer here
which is rook c1 of course
now we want to use the fact that this
one on c7 is very very tasty
it has a curry sauce and we just want to
swallow it
so let's say the black plays including
d5
and now rook c5 very nice intermediate
move
and i want to ask you what happens if
black takes
on g2 so
white plays and wins
now we can't go a long castle right not
anymore
so but there is a very nice move in this
position
and forget about material yeah
we have to be aggressive in this
position
try to enter in black's position
rook c7 well rook c7 it's it's all right
but then after 97
i think black is fine because of the
queen b4 check we got key in f6
so no roxy 7 is actually losing so
a better move we have to use the fact
that all black pieces are in the
background
queen f4 it's uh well queen f4
you can just play queen takes a h1
kindly two and knight f6
and again not clear so
this is the weakest point if we attack
this guy
and imagine a queen landing on e6
then black will suffer checkmate right
so yeah that's right luis ray fantastic
queen e3
that's a great move because now if white
if black takes a rook on h1 king d2
there's no way
of stopping queen e6 now you can't go
queen c6 you cannot go back with queen
g5
and then after queen e6 black has to
resign so let's
check for example knight d7 we can just
take
and king d8 only move just knight f7 and
queen e8 checkmate so queen is
3 sacrificing a whole rook
so that's why queen g2 is losing because
of this queen e3 fantastic
variation so we checked
we checked queen g2 so the only move for
black here is
queen d7 and now again
improve our pieces now e6 is protected
so
probably we have to find another square
so
f7 is a tasty squared and remember we
can
combine threats for example attacking c7
and the square f7 so
what is the move that tackle attack
sorry
both outputs
what's up injen staff how are you doing
man
everything all right enjoying life
enjoying the winter winter is coming
winter is coming i hate winter you know
so my main target in life
is to be able to stay in flip flops
like eight months per year so last
year's we were traveling to latin
america to
to give some exhibitions simuls and
conferences
but this year is just impossible right
because coronavirus that's right
qwerty roman nicolas mr toy potent toti
potent
so queen f4 that's right and now
let's say black plays c6 and now just
rookie five
followed by rookie six still i will take
white in this position
so let's say after short castle shark
castle
and i would take white in this position
because we just won the queen right even
if black takes on e5 just d takes c5 and
it black takes
black play sorry knight b to d7 rook e6
and it's true that black has a
one rook and two pieces but we got one
more pawn and this skin is actually
uh in the middle of the board right so
we got ideas like queen e3
and after king f7 we got queen b3 and
take on b7
so what i mean is we're gonna get some
more material and if you guys check the
engines they say this is
also very very interesting for white
so so so so so
so black if black takes on c4 it's gonna
be very very risky so there are other
choices for black in this position
so queen d7 and here
we just go long castle and again it's
not
an immediate checkmate or something like
that right but one half
has to smell to smell the position right
to call it uh like that because now
i mean we don't need to know that we're
gonna checkmate black skin in like in 10
moves but we
should know that we have enough
contemplate with just analyzing the
position because we got
the e file the skin is still in the
center my key is extremely safe on c1
and when this root comes to the e file
now e6 is gonna suffer again also the e5
square for the
knight is very very tasty right
uh if you can't smell you are probably
positive that's right
that's right on kurt so
yeah so bishop b4 intermediate move
okay so i think we're done with this
king e7 variation
but we still have to analyze after
knight x f7
kintex f7 knight g5 kine8 and here
we're gonna take this pawn on e6 and
basically
black has two main options what would
you play here with the black pieces if
you had to choose
let's say two moves what would you play
here with the black pieces
queen d7 okay
queen d7 is one of your suggestions
which is actually losing
because of bishop c4 queen f6 that's a
main line
um card and there is another main line
in this position which is maybe the most
natural move you protect g7
and that's right mr qwerty you pin
this knight on e6 so let's start
checking this
e7 uh this queen is seven sorry just uh
to remember you guys that after this
uh lecture we're gonna have another
lecture
where we are analyzing games of the week
and i'm gonna show you one of the most
instructive games in the last months
it's calcium versus study from norway
chess from the last round
probably you guys are also following
norway chess and
they are playing the ninth round i
believe right now
in norway so there's actually uh carlsen
versus firoza
going on carlson is leading the
tournament and the
iranian kid is just second and now he is
already i think number 17th
in the wall so we're a player right
okay who do you think will win firoza or
carlson i think
uh firoza has the white pieces today and
i was just checking the line before i
came with you guys here to this lecture
and the opening is quite interesting so
anything can happen right
and in tie breaks as well as i told you
uh the other day in one of these
lectures
like videotakes is a very strong player
in in rapid
in rapid chess so anything can happen in
case of an
uh armageddon so queen is seven so
bishop c4 developing a piece preparing
for sure castle and bringing about
another piece
to the e file bishop g7 and this
actually corresponds to a game
between one of my best friends ivara
jerez grandmaster from spain
he went for short castle he was playing
an indian player in
spanish tournament in 2016.
okay so short castle bishop b6 bishop e6
and queen f6 of course you can't
really take this bishop on e8 e6 because
of rookie one right and there's a pin
so queen f6 in order to develop this
knife to e7
rookie one from ivara 97
and this skin is always in trouble
because this bishop is doing a fantastic
job stopping
black's front castle on the castle in
sorry on the key inside or
queen side and here again
what do you play with the white pieces
give me a move guys
give me a move actually you can get a
pawn
with a sequence of two moves
so again 4c moves i'm gonna
be insisting on this like hell
bishop c8 bishop c8 is quite strange
but it's interesting actually it's very
interesting
so let's say i can play knight d7 bishop
b7 and i guess you gave
black too many tempi but very very
interesting maybe this is also good
for for white i like that i like that
actually so bishop c8 probably was a
very good move
and also queen h5 queen b fight that's
that's right nice music
queen h5 this was the game g6 and queen
b5
4c moves checks very simple chess
so in the game
queen h5 they went queen g6 and queen b5
anyway
and here knight b to c6 anivara went for
an intermediate move
bishop f5 attacking the queen and after
queen f6 we
can develop another piece
and creating some tricks and traps
so here
why to play i like that you guys
are being so interactive this
always makes the the class more fun and
i feel like i'm not crazy you know
when i started working in chess 24 uh
like six years ago or something i was
living in germany i was doing my phd in
the hamburger university
so we started doing commentary on top
events in spanish
and there was nobody following the
commentary because
i mean the web was new right and uh
so imagine talking for six hours
non-stop
with nobody watching you probably we
have like two people
one was my mom and the other was my
mom's
colleague so i felt like a crazy man
right just talking
alone in front of a camera for six hours
nobody listening
yeah bishop g5 just for fun that's right
because black can take a g5 because
there is bishop d7
and then we grab the queen the game
continued with a6
queen b7 queen g5
queen e8 and 98 and ivara ended up
winning this
game because now it's got like a rook
and
three pawns for two pieces and the kid
in the center so
basically white was much much better
okay so this is the line
after queen e7 the other option for
black
here is to go queen f6
which is the most played variation and
here
bishop c4 just defending this knight on
e6
and knight e7
okay so here we continue with bishop g5
attacking the queen developing with the
temple
and queen g6 and
queenie ii what are we threatening after
queen e2
let's say for example that black plays
h6
which is a terrible move how do we win
the game here
so why to play and win in this position
very simple chess again yeah we are not
discovering the fire here right
we are not discovering fire knight c7
knight c7 you still have king d7 though
and after knight a8 i just take this
bishop and then it's not clear that this
knight is going out but
more simple than that jorge jimenez is
too strong today
and yeah you are right bishop e7 just
wins because now after king e7 there is
knight f4
well knight four are not so sure because
knight f4 you got queen e4
so i guess you can play yeah knight f4
queen e4 and i guess knight g6 yeah this
is also enough
but uh what i mean that after bishop e7
now knight c7 just
wins but also just long castle
and then this skin is very very bad
placed and we are not in a hurry
actually to take on c7
i mean basically anything is just
winning in this position right
okay so bishop g5 queen g6 queen e2
and queen e4 now of course black is
intending to
exchange queens but the problem is that
g7 is hanging so knight takes g7
king d8 and this position even though
black managed to
trade queens i think white is much
better again
let's say bishop c2 rook c1 bishop g6
and f4
and again this skin is in the center and
then we got these ideas with f5 f6
and you guys check this with the engine
it says it's
just a decisive advantage for white
okay so we i think we're almost done
with this bishop g6 variation
so let's go to check the last two main
options for black
the first one is bishop e7 here
and now the question i said to you that
we're gonna
sacrifice in almost every
uh variation after knight g5 but now my
question is would you take on f7 right
now
would you take on f7
is it working the sacrifice right now
or it's just rubbish somebody called me
oh my taxes but advisor this is never
good news
you know my tax
advisor is just calling me well i'll
talk to him later
so would you sacrifice on f7 rubbish
95 better well 95 just uh
just loses well you got i mean it's
interesting because you got queen h5
but i guess after g6 you're gonna trade
queens and this is not our
main idea but very interesting but no
the point is after knight takes f7
kintex f7 95
now black goes simply to f8 now the f8
square is available and basically after
queen h5 there is always queen e8
or bishop b8 and there is also knight f6
in case you give a check on the f file
so basically this is just losing for
white so this is the only case
where we are not going to be able to
sacrifice and then we have to play
a little bit more camp more count sorry
so bishop e7 and here we're just gonna
play bishop d3
now again black has several options
knight d7 is one of 10
but also different options for example
h6 again this is just a terrible move
because of boom knight f7
black has weakened the light squares and
also this knight is joining the party
there is a nice salsa party
on the e5 square also on the light
squares
so keen f8 and knight g6 just getting
the rook
if the king goes to e8 now boom queen h5
and then this is gonna end in checkmate
okay so h6 is not possible so you're
showing these kind of positions
also for example bishop f3
how do we take on f3 we take with the
knight or with the queen
you gotta decide i mean i hope there's
nobody saying that he wants to take with
the pawn
right because this is just losing in the
spot because of bishop g5 and then
we're gonna cry
so taking with the knight which is not
bad of course
or taking with the queen
attacking f7 and also b7
that's right um queen f3 is much
stronger i mean 93 is not bad
these positions are also very playable
for white we got the bishop
white is a little bit better but the
point is at the queen f3
basically black is in real trouble
because f7 is under attack and after
bishop g5
we just take on g5 and now black has to
take on g5 and b7 is just hanging
and the rook on a8 falls which with a
bit advantage for white
and if black goes let's say queen c8
then we can just open the position blow
everything up in the center
open the position for this couple of
monsters
right and this is just uh well bishop f5
for example
knight g7 and long castle and no one's
gonna save this
poor guy in the center of the board
okay so bishop f3 not a very good idea
for black in this position either
so what else after bishop d3 well
knight g7 is the main move but also
let's check some other options we check
h6
also bishop f3 bishop g5 we can try to
transpose
to the same line after taking on g5
and after bishop f3 just queen of three
same position
and after knight f6 again we just go
sure castle bishop f3 and queen f3
and it's true that black survives but
we got the bishop and a very nice
position
okay so after bishop d3
still knight d7 is the best move i
believe
there is also the possibility for black
to go knight f6
but we have already said what happens
after knight f6
although in this case it's just not
winning immediately right
so what do we play if black goes knight
f6
come on guys tell me
you want some cookies
sir are there any opening transpositions
into the fort knox i believe this is
just the only way to to get into the
fort knox e4 e6 d4 d5
and knight d2 or knight c3 black takes
on e4 and then bishop d7 bishop
c6
yeah knight e5 is the best move here in
this position
because what black wants to do black
wants to go sure castle on h6
and send our guy to h3 so we play 95
attacking f7
share castle and then we just go short
castle
black can never take this pawn on d4
because of bishop takes
h7 and then the queen is hanging
so if black goes h6 now
we just go knight f3 and we have a nice
setup here
for example let's say b2b4 we should
take c4 knight takes e4
and queen e2 and we have better position
because we have a nice
space advantage we can develop very
easily with bishop f4
rook 81 rook f2 e1
h3 for example and also we have some
attacking ideas related
by sacrificing on h6 this rook can join
the party on the third rank
in some positions what i mean is this is
just very easy and healthy to play with
the white pieces
okay so knight f6
and finally we come to check the main
line with knight d7
and sure castle
almost everybody is playing here queenie
too but i think short castle is good
enough for an advantage so this is why i
recommend you
i'm gonna recommend you this this move
which is very natural of course
and the knight f6
it's a very bad move again so here black
has
several options h6 bishop f3
and i think this is all
so knight f6 let's start with this
come on guys give me your best move here
for white
as you can see in many positions the
sacrifice works
so that's why it's so tricky for black
to play
because black has to pay attention all
the time to this sacrifice on f7
knight e5 now is not that good because
of knight takes e5
sorry and knight g7 on black spine
e5 is under attack now the knight on g5
is under attack
so nope 95 is not the best move mithran
okay knight to f7
keen f7 knight g5 sorry
king g8 and knight takes e6
and this position is better for white
again let's say
rookie one bishop d6 and bishop f5
and look at this position the king is on
g8 the queen is on c8
very very passive whenever the queen
wants to join the party on e8
there is a rook on e5 only one so
reminding her
that that's not a good square we got
ideas with bishop g5 we got ideas with
c4 and c5 with c4 and d5 again
this is just a dream right for the white
pieces
okay so knight f6 not a very good move
again
and therefore we said there are two
more options for example bishop f3
knight takes a three
here it's just not possible to take with
the queen because after bishop takes g5
now the knight is already on d7 so
taking on b7 doesn't make any sense
because now
black can just move the rook or even
queen g8 and everything is well
protected right
so in such positions uh omkar is saying
such positions from knight d7 karo even
if suck
goes wrong it's still difficult for
black at least our level that's
completely right i mean what i mean
is even though the engine says 0.00
that implies that the position is
extremely hard to play
for black pieces because even though
black is material up the engine says
0.00 and in many cases with only one
move or
with a couple of moves
okay some somebody's writing in chinese
right in the chat
still my chinese is not very good even
though i used to live with a chinese guy
with my master's in italy
his name was way one and we used to call
him juanito
he was a very very funny guy he taught
me some chinese for example
that means i'm hungry
i'm thirsty or the other way around
right okay so after bishop f3
now we gotta take with the knight and
then reach these kind of positions where
black is solid
but we're just better because we got the
bishop
for example knight f6 queen e2 sure
castle
c3 c5 and bishop f4
and after bringing our rook to d1 this
is a little bit better for white this
corresponds to a game between paco alejo
which is
our spanish number one is a 2700 player
number 30 in the wall
more or less so very strong
okay automatic player
at amateur level nobody almost plays
bishop g7 not many people plays this
fort knox variation i mean i've found
i played like at least
five to six classical games with the
white pieces against uh
against the fort knox and with players
with average
2100 2200 so some people
and of course we cannot cover the whole
thing yeah chess is so big that
in many cases just to have a repertoire
against everything is just
nonsense right okay so
we were analyzing this variation short
castle and h6
and now it doesn't work the sacrifice
because
after king f7 the e5 square is well
covered for this knight on d7
and we cannot continue with knight e5
followed by queen h5 so
it's not a good business to take on f7
that's why
we have to assume that sacrifice not
working and just go back to e4 let's say
knight f6
knight xf6 knight f6 and probably this
is one of the most solid lines
for black against this
knight e to g5 probably b2b7 is the best
way and this is the only variation that
doesn't allow
white to take on f7 so c3
sure castle rookie one and as i told you
this bishop is
a little bit clumsy so in many positions
black wants to
to to trade for the knight on f3 queen
takes a3
c5 cd dc sorry bishop c5 and bishop f4
and even though position is solid for
black i will take
the white pieces we got a nice majority
on the queen side
three versus two for the end games could
be very interesting and also the
bishop pair so if i will if i had to
choose i will take the white pieces
without any doubt all right so
let's analyze
the last move a main line which is
knight g7 and here
we're gonna sacrifice again on f7 the
engine will say
that black can survive but with very
very
strong moves and unique moves in many
cases
so key in f7 and of course knight to g5
check and here what do you think is the
best move for black
kidney 8 or kin e7 what would you play
with the black pieces here you got 10
seconds to decide 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3
2 1 go you're gonna play
kidney eight or kidney seven one is good
the other one is not good
this is what why i'm saying this line is
so tricky for black because i mean
it's very tough to decide here
kini 8 kidney 7 yeah omkar says skinny
eight mitran says skinny seven well
the best move is kini eight kidney seven
is just losing
so that's why i like so much this line
because in many positions in many cases
your opponent will fall for the trap
so king e7 is very bad because of
bishop c4 and we are just taking this
guy on e6
black cannot stop that if bishop d5 i
believe we can just taken queen e2
so knight f6 96
queen eight and sure castle and after
rookie one
black is gonna struggle a lot in this
position the king cannot hide on d8 the
king cannot hide on f7 because of this
diagonal i mean in conclusion this is
just a disaster for black right
that's right luis kine8 seems the safest
on e7 is so exposed
i completely agree with you so kinney8
and here bishop d3 we're gonna play
this move what is our threat well we are
threatening to go
queen h5 in this position and just wins
for example
let's say black dash something stupid a6
now
queen h5 g6 ba boom
bishop takes g6 and queen g6
kenny seven and checkmate on e6 so
black has to parry that thread and black
has several options here in this
position after bishop d3
one option is knight g to these to f6
the other option is knight d to f6
the other option is queen f6
and finally g6
let's start with the move g6
which is a terrible move because of
knight e6
queen e7 and guess what shortcast oh
of course because now black can take
this knight on e6 and rookie one it's
coming
and travels for black so this is
terrible move
let's start with knight g to f6 which is
also losing
after sure castle bb7
knight takes e6 queen c8 and knight x
g7 and we got enough material for the
sacrifice piece
right the kinix still exposed so
basically this is just very good for
white
all right so
the best two moves for black here are
queen f6 and
knight d to f6 let's start with queen f6
which is maybe
the move that makes more sense because
it stops
queen h5 in the sense that now g6 is
gonna be possible because the queen is
just protecting that square
and also it's covering e6 so now we're
gonna continue with queen e2
putting some pressure and let's say
bishop d6
now we can take on e6 and again
troubles for black for example if knight
b to e7
we just play bishop g5 and after queen
f7 only move bishop c4
and again some threats knight c7
the engine says that the only move here
available for black is bishop
king f7 and now after bishop c for this
looks almost winning for white but black
has
this move knight b6 and
you can check this with the engine it
said that is around equal
but i wouldn't want to be in black's
hands in this position
it's just so dangerous for example you
can always have a repetition if you want
knight g5 kin f8 knight e6
but you can also play for the wing with
the move bishop b3
okay so queen f6
and let's check the last option with
knight d
to f6 sorry guys one sec
just opening the chat here
again it was closed so knight d
to f6 and again queen e2 also knight e6
is very interesting followed by sure
castle
right but queen e2
and now queen d7 for example
that's different options for black queen
e7
knight e7 bishop d6
sorry and queen d7 for example if black
goes bishop d6
we can just go sure castle and again
next move probably is gonna be
rookie one at some point we're gonna
take on e6
this bishop can come to c4 and in
practice is very tough
for black to defend sane applies after
queen e7
he can continue with shark castle king
d7
rookie one kinzier trying to hide that
king
and now knight e6 and again
you don't need to know uh how to
continue in these positions you just
need to know that you have enough
compensation for the piece
you have a strong knight on e6 all black
pieces are in the background
c4 and d5 are coming just
uh attacking this bishop reinforcing the
knight on the e6
this bishop can be developed by a g5
also
f4 for impression c7 and in general this
is very tough to play with the black
pieces
okay so knight e7 which
doesn't look like the most natural move
right green knight e6 queen d7
and again sure same ideas rookie one
c4 d5 the king cannot
escape from the from the center right
because
you cannot castle because you took
already upon an f7
last move queen d7 you can just play
short castle
and again same same same stuff let's say
bishop d6
and c4 which threats
threatens d5 right and i wouldn't
like to be in blacks in black's hands in
this position
so basically this is all this is all
what i wanted to show you this is my
repertoire against this line so i'm not
hiding anything
this is all i analyzed this was uh hours
of work
and i would be very very happy if you
guys can use this weapon in some of your
games
and i would be very happy if after using
this
repertoire what we just checked here you
guys text me a message in my
social media for example in instagram i
would be very happy also to answer any
kind of questions that you have related
to this variation
and always eager to help you guys and uh
there's nothing that makes me more happy
than uh getting to know that somebody
has used some of the lines uh that i
shared with you in in a classical
tournament so
just remember just play knight f3
knight g5 and almost against any move
just take on f7 just play knight g5 then
bishop c4
just bring the pieces put pressure on e6
don't be afraid
black is the one that has to be your
friend and mainly because you have
prepared this line you have checked all
these lines and
you know more than your opponent does
and uh
only move where we cannot go crazy is
be7 we're gonna be
more count bishop d three queenie two
knight e4 and then played this kind of
position which is also
more than healthy okay guys so we're
gonna make
a a little stop of let's say five
minutes
and then we're gonna come back to check
one of the games between magnus carlsen
and addy arie antari from norway chess
i guarantee you this is this was one of
the most instructive games
uh actually the title that we gave to
this
game was norwegian church
torture so magnus carlsen doing his
stuff
okay guys thanks for being here and see
you
in five minutes don't run away take just
some zoda
some popcorns and see you and thanks for
being so interactive
see you guys if you drink don't drive